[Music]
thank you
I'm a senior advisor at the U.S state
Department in the office of the under
secretary for arms control and
International Security affairs
I came in as a nuclear engineer fresh
out of MIT focusing on radiation
detection how do you use these different
Technologies to help build confidence in
Arms Control agreements that are
designed to avoid war
she has made a career of humanity and
that's something Martin Luther King Jr
talked about doing in the fight for
equal rights she's done it through this
space of bringing technology and science
and Society together for good
[Music]
summer research program lovingly known
as MSRP it's an opportunity to come to
one of the most celebrated and revered
institutions technically speaking and
demonstrate to you that you already have
inside of you what you need to compete
and not just compete but to thrive
I was actually the first black woman to
earn a PhD in nuclear engineering from
MIT
I definitely benefited from a very
Lively community that was invested in my
success and we are always have our eyes
out for who's next and how we can
continue to support them through this
very
um rigorous program
she was attending a lot of the town
halls and forums we were having talking
about Dei and just brought so much
perspective and kindness and love
as a mother as a scientist as a policy
maker I deeply understand that it's our
turn
to fight this fight it's our turn to do
our work and I'm deeply grateful to the
MIT Community
um the participants in today's
events who are committed to doing that
work
[Music]